e
for
good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation before we get started can
please
FL States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
all okay uh we're going to get in I'll
open up our
full committee work
session uh we've got two bills
listed um House Bill 1273 FN and House
Bill
1637 to try to make some some uh seating
available um it's been agreed basically
we gave uh originally talked about an
interim study on H Bill
1273 uh we decided to give it a few more
weeks and came up with more Road blocks
so we are going to be moving forward the
executive session with an interim study
again so there's not really anything to
talk about in the work session for
1273 so um on 16 House Bill
1637 relative to reducing requirements
for vehicle inspections I'd like to
reach out and thank representative sers
for doing all the leg work um who did
email out to the committee yesterday uh
after talking um
actually several times on this uh this
is a a draft a suggested draft U that uh
we came up with and I think it takes out
some of the onerous things uh in
particular actually you know what I'll
let representative sers explain this
he's he's had his head into it more than
I all right thank you Mr chair and
instead of going back to the original
yes it did take out uh one of the main
things it took out is uh renewing your
license uh on the day uh that uh excuse
me renewing your inspection um maybe
when you buy the car at that point
instead of on your your licensed birth
month at that point so that's one of the
big areas that was taken out uh another
area was taken out which was on uh the
very back but it had to do with um uh
broken door latches you know at that
point so because we want to make sure
people can get in and out of their
counter rank so let me just go over the
uh first few things here the first
section is new uh you know where the
department shall not require an
inspection station perform inspections
within any uh minimum maximum amount of
time I mean that that on number one is
new uh section number two on line eight
uh amended and the amendment part here
is going from either a 10day or a 20-day
and just going consistently with 30 days
throughout it so on line
12 and on line 18 this is on page one
and also on line 20 all right so that's
that's what's being changed there the
third uh number three section here um is
a change as well and again trying to be
consistent with 30 days so this is a if
they uh have a failure here they have 30
days to get it corrected and especially
with the garages today it's stuff I'm
finding it very difficult I have to
schedule my car two weeks out and I'm
saying I need to have a spare car just
to have a car you know a vehicle to get
around so we need this extra time and
also for those folks that might not have
the the actual means of just putting the
car in the shop and have to work on it
themselves they need a little extra time
to do that work as well especially where
those are procrastinators and they wait
until maybe the last day of inspection
and they get it in there finally and and
out it fails so that's that's some of
the reasons for those changes number
four is a new section there again just
aligning in this case the first one was
departments this one is now it says new
law enforcement officers shall uh shall
require inspections within any it shall
I wonder if that's a mistake but I'll
check that out I thought I thought maybe
it should be shall not require
inspections with any minimum maximum
amount of time so I'm going to just
question on line three on page
too um just to verify that that is
should be shall or shall not all right
uh on Section Five it's a change and the
change is down on uh line 26 27 and
possibly 28 the one thing it had in
there is they had one word in there
linear all right that word linear was
taken out so it's just cracks all right
because you could have you know a a a
diagonal crack or whatever at that point
Point yet the you know that's just the
casing the directional still
works um number six um or that was the
headlamp section number six is the uh
directionals uh same idea um looking at
line 37 going on to the next
page page three one two and three um all
right so that is
there and
number seven is a change again they I
took on on line seven uh it used to say
linear cracks linear cracks no it just
says
cracks um
section8 is new we've added uh 58b
window
functions all right uh no vehicle shall
fail inspection due to a inability of a
window to open or
close all right number nine uh this is
under ruem
or a change to that adding rule
118 all right it says no rule
shall uh require inspection failure when
there are cracks in any of the
functional headlamps or
reflectors 10 uh has to do with the
brakes um representative Walsh had a
separate Amendment he's going to do The
Brak Po and I've added it all into this
one amendment to make everything all all
inclusive again looking at line
24 uh through 36 here and I'm going to
say most of this stuff came out of rules
and and uh maybe representative Walsh
can talk about some of that but the they
definitely uh lines 25
27 um I'm going to say all this stuff
actually came out of rules unless
representative was wants to add a little
more to that and that goes on to the
last page uh
again at that point just uh
changes uh page four 1 through
7 and lastly it would take effect 60
days after
passage so hopefully I explained most of
it and I'll I'll take some questions
what I can
answer thank you representative and
before I go to questions I will
reiterate sections line well line 24
through 36 on page three and on the back
page page four uh the majority of that
is from Rules just putting into the
statute uh the reason for the change I
don't know about you but the I receive
countless and countless and countless
complaints every year over the word rust
on
rotors and it was the way it's in rules
it's just very subjective so we looked
at it and I said well why don't we just
remove the word rust because the the
mirror presence of rust isn't good cause
for failing pitting is and so and you
you can't have pitting without rest so
so we left the pitting and just took the
subjective word rest out essentially
keeping everything else the same uh the
first draft of the amendment I saw
didn't look at the Linings or or or
shoes or pads but this one does and
it'll all um be included in RSA 26628
which already does have a break section
on it so that was the reason for it just
to remove some of the subjectivity
because you can buy a brand new vehicle
and just because it's got a little
orange on the road doesn't mean there's
anything wrong with it the only time
there's a problem from what we can see
is if it's cracked or if it really does
diminish stopping power if there's
issues with the friction surface
itself um so with that being said go
ribs and sellers yeah I just have one
more add here on page to actually on
line
26 uh since uh the chair mentioned
roster we we did uh cross off rust there
so just want to point that
out thank you sir representative
Hill thank you Mr chairman um I have a
question about uh L uh page one I guess
line five through 7 and what does that
do that page two line 3 through five
thing could I ask you to repeat that I
didn't hear the the last part um L page
two 3 through
five and page one line 5 through 7 I
think I thought it looks to me like
they're doing the same thing yeah one
one is departments the key word there is
departments the other one is law
enforcement and and again on page two I
had Circle the uh where it says law
enforcement officer shall require I'm
wondering if that's supposed to say
shall not require as on page
one on line five it says departments
require once once's law enforcement
once's
department we need both I don't
know um that those both came from the
original bill so I guess it's up to us
whether we think we need both or if they
could be both mentioned in the same
paragraph um or if they're needed at all
that's that's why we're having this
exercise now so
um I think though if we do decide to
leave it the way it is I do agree that
the knot should be added for the page
two lines three through five but just my
take on it at this point any other
thoughts representative Jack uh thank
you I'm going to push back a little bit
on the page two because the difference
is that on page on line three it starts
out with the word
no
you Mr chair I'm wondering if if I may
yeah go ahead um I wondering if we
should actually just add the law
enforcement part to page one line five
department and law enforcement and just
get rid
two
um that actually number four alog
together that section
well if we are okay with the intent
of paragraph Roman three on page two and
the intent of Roman 8 I mean 13 that's
not going to require another amendment
if we leave it the way it is if we want
to move it and just add law enforcement
to line five then we'll have to go back
to OS but again it's all what it's this
is what we as a committee think we
should be doing that's just my opinion
representative C I just noticed that
both of these are listed as new
paragraphs so they are not in
existing uh law so we would have to
decide whether to correct that or not or
to merge them because we can't just
ignore
it section one and section four are both
new
paragraphs yeah but that's okay so long
as they so as long as they're written
correctly
any we'll take a look at it though we'll
continue to I I did notice that uh page
one that part one that goes in U uh RSA
colon I guess that's a one it says
I uh whereas um the other one is in a
different
61a and that may be an error on the
first one have showing a Roman eye
instead
of the number
one we'll confirm that in a minute may
not it may or may not be any other
thoughts of yeah go ahead y
um I don't recall but maybe I'm just not
recalling do we normally require the
department not to do something and law
enforcement not to do something or do we
just assume that if the department says
don't do it law enforcement follows the
Department or vice versa is is it normal
to have both items that's a great
question beats me oh we can look into
it how about our resident expert over
it
did you have something
represent
go okay um my question is on the term
cracks in the two sections uh is there a
point where a crack can
become to the point where it needs
to be a factor in the inspection because
this kind of like eliminates all cracks
can a crack become significant enough
that should this be limited to
insignificant or minor crack
uh is a spider crack that like makes the
life flare and blind
everybody a potential problem or I'm not
sure I I think for me the reason this
was put in the original Bill and and
I'll ask repon sellers about the word
lineal in a
minute should the mere fact there's a
crack there I don't think is an issue
myself when a crack becomes so bad that
it starts letting water in naturally the
bulb is going to fail on its own um you
can't a bulb will stay lit if it keeps
getting wet um and I know it was put in
just because of the sheer cost of these
things with insignificant cracks however
if we do put in a an adjective we're
getting back to subjectivity again right
so
representes yeah thank you Mr chairman I
I actually was hoping that we could ask
someone in the audience about this
because I I totally get that we don't
want the water to get in and affect the
headlights operation but not being a
lighting expert I'm concerned that um if
there's a crack does it change the
directional way that the light projects
out in front of the vehicle do you
follow do you follow my question so I
don't have the answer for that but I was
hoping somebody might I'll invite
anybody from the Department of Safety
that's familiar with inspections if
they'd like to ask a couple of questions
good
morning
um if I understand I still need you to
introduce yourself I'm sorry I'm Carl
holiston I'm a Staff Sergeant with State
Police Troop G um we we oversee um
inspection stations cardi I'm also in
the motor carrier side of things as well
so if I understand the question
is about the statement that inhibit the
ability for a light to project as
prescribed in the section is that what
we're asking I'm
sorry I'll let represent SES re ask the
question yeah so so what I'm trying to
determine
is obviously the whole point of
headlights Beyond being a able to see
more it part of the inspectional
criteria I believe is that how they line
up and and where they're directed The
Beam is directed correct my concern is
or question is does a crack in the lens
then affect the way the beam projects
and if it does then I'm a little
concerned about this language so to
answer your question both yes and
no and and again that's the thing and I
I know you had talked about some a term
or terms being subjective this would be
one of them if it's in the dead center
of it potentially no if it's on the edge
potentially yes depending on where it is
to drill down to the point where you
define in
this this one is acceptable this one is
not would be extremely hard to do um but
I I think the the term that you have in
here which is um cracks in the headlamp
or reflecting surface shall not cause
I'm sorry um that inhibit the ability
for light to project as described in the
section that sort of clarifies a little
bit but it's still subjective to the
person that's actually conducting the
inspection um and I agree some of these
headlight assemblies are extremely
expensive and just because it has a a
crack in one area of it that is down to
the left or something like that would
not affect the safety of it Mr chairman
may I have uh may I follow up with
another sure um question of the the
expert thank you um on page three on
line
34 I I understand why we're we're going
to pitting but I'm worried about again
the subjectiveness of what what is
extensive and I don't know if that's an
issue as well you know how do how would
that page line uh page three line 34 I
believe it it talks about regarding uh
breake drums and disc brake shell fail
inspection only where the discs discs or
drums show excessive mechanical damage
other than wear and show evidence of
elimination or excessive pitting on the
friction surfaces
surface such that it would either affect
the proper brake operation except that
Rush shall not be a reason for
inspection
so extensive pitting you're right um
and the the issue becomes um that would
affect the proper brake operation again
that's that's subjective as
well so there is
not
um to describe it in
writing um again would be hard to do and
you're still relying on whoever is
performing the inspection to make a
judgment call as to whether or not it's
not
so you know we I struggled with OS on
that one line too whether or not the
even word extensive needs to be there um
I could live with it or without it so
you know we can talk about that further
I do see some other questions
representative
D my concern is this is very
subjective and if if I were a dealer I
would I would uh try to utilize the
language to increase my business I can
certainly assum that would happen it
could happen that's right and and I have
a real concern with that so that the
language is clear enough so that it's
not subjective if you know what I'm
saying somehow that's what we're seeking
to do but okay but again when you're
looking at automotive parts and uh how
many inspection stations do we have
that's the challenge we have
uh I see and I apologize I sorry hand up
representa
pondon thank you Mr chair um on the
crack lens issue uh my concern is
nowadays we've got the LED bulbs and any
crack particularly particularly on brake
lights can be blinding to the vehicles
behind and most of these lenses also
have their the rear uh backup lights um
and furthermore where you can
inexpensively buy a specific lens tape
to cover the crack thus covering the the
the blinding uh especially LED light
bulb
issues I I just don't support this part
of the legislation and if I could do you
Mr chair ask the uh the sergeant uh his
viewpoint on uh that lens tape repair so
you don't have to replace the whole
assembly I shall I don't know where tail
lights are even mentioned here but I
might be wrong this deals with headlamps
yes and as far as I know even tape on a
headlamp is not currently legal but I'll
I'll let safety respond to
that so to answer your question
um
I looking at page
reflectors it talks about uh crack shall
not cause inspection
failure and if I'm correct so you're
referring specifically to brake lights
or tail lights right if I could line six
either part of tail lamps or or
reflectors
okay so you are correct they they do
make tape to to cover these things and
to my knowledge of the um 3200
administrative
rules that deal with um vehicle
inspection I don't recall seeing a
Prohibition on putting tape on a tail
lenss
I I I I don't think I've ever looked
specifically for that but I don't I
don't remember seeing a Prohibition
against it thank you and again Mr CH
that's my point I think it's an inex
inexpensive solution
to uh dare I call it a blinding problem
a lot of these LED lights are extremely
bright a crack or especially a hole and
this tape you can get at any automotive
repair or Walmart whatever and it's
specifically for lenses thank you Mr
chair yeah well to as a solution would
you be okay adding language to make sure
that the tape is applied to the rear
lights or anything red in the rear on
only because all it says is that a
cracked one won't be caused for
inspection so for failure of inspection
so if we can agree on that knowing that
the tape is allowed we could mention
that it would need to be used uh that's
that's an option okay something to think
about for a
minute don't we love work sessions
representative Fox thank you Mr chair
and um I specifically from personal
experience would prefer the language for
the tape to be included um uh a a
failure in $700 later um and we had the
tape and and it was it was uh our
inspection was denied um another may I
ask another question Mr
chair um considering the cracks and and
the um the possibility of the
projection and knowing that
subjected the way it's worded in the the
language here um what about the
projection of a tail light with a
crack does it diminish either does it
diminish the um the
lightness in the headlight or the tail
question trying to be
allinclusive um I think would be very
hard uh a minor crack that's an inch or
less um probably wouldn't cause any
problem whatsoever I'm and I'm just
speculating um knowing what I know about
headlights and tail lights however
depending on where it actually is either
in the head lamp or in the tail lamp uh
could
um cause the alteration of the project
ction of the light as far as a tail
light goes or a stop
lamp I obviously I've seen cracks in
them or actually holes in them and they
emit a little more white light than they
would if they were whole but I don't
think on a tail light anyways having a
crack on it diminishes the the amount of
light that comes out of it um as far as
the headlight goes and again um H having
read this again there are
still
um it's still
that somebody's going to have to make
the determination whether it um affects
the ability to perform as it was
designed to that that's where
um somebody's going to have to make that
determination
I thank you for the answer on the tail
lights are are you good with that on
that back to the headlights though
um what if we were to spell out the
difference between a sealed beam which I
believe the glass actually does have
something to do with the trajectory as
opposed to one of it's just a a plastic
cover now because most of the the
trajectory is created by the reflection
tub in the back of the light yes sir
that is correct and that's actually a
great uh way to to try to clarify this
even more correct sealed beam if a
sealed beam is cracked it's going to
fail right uh that's that's that's a
given that a matter of time so that
would be one distinction that you would
that you could make is that you know any
crack in a sealed beam would be you know
reason for
failure because obviously eventually it
would fail and as far as
a either
projection I guess the best term would
be projection headlight because that
wouldn't be inclusive of incandescent
hallogen and
led um the projection uh style headlight
any crack in the
reflective
um part which is typically behind the
bulb that would probably be a lot more
specific as far as a crack on the lens
in front of the
bulb as long as it
in and again affect the projection of it
that that would be fine but I I'd still
with inhibiting the ability to project
light as prescribed you know by this
which typically would mean by the by the
manufacturer so you can do away with one
part of it with the um sealed beam but
as I think you would have
to the projection style lights again I'm
just thinking out loud here I would
think you would have to say that cracks
that don't allow moisture to enter would
not cause uh failure of inspection if
properly there you
go so yes I think that probably would
better
I yeah I saw somebody over here was that
you represent rbo yes I this maybe this
last line of discussion May supersede
this but I guess in line 26 where we
have that you know that new talized
language that inhibit the ability for
light to project as described in this
section it's not in the next sentence
and I was thinking ini if we add so say
cracks and a headlamp tail light
reflecting surface that inhibit the
ability etc etc shall not cause
inspection failure it sounds like
Sergeant saying that's still too vague
based on you know what the manufacturer
expectations would be I my My overall
concern is now in trying get everything
you know we're trying to not be too big
and now we're trying to get everything
in there and I it seems really
challenging and I you know I think we
can just keep going that's that's my
concern um and I and I want to have a
better understanding why where the rules
function I guess as opposed to the
statute for for covering some of this or
if there's if it all needs to be in
statute or all should be in
statute well we we we decided to do this
with rust a few years ago because and
there's no way for us who receive all
the phone calls and complaints for us to
really have a legitimate way to change
the rules so when we identified things
in rules that we just looked as too
subjective that's when we started moving
things into statute which supersede and
that's all we're trying to do here is to
continue the conversation that we've had
for the last few years on trying to make
people hate this program less and so I
didn't never said it was going to be
easy uh but um and and then we could
certainly even do more uh but I think
these are just ones that are really the
ones people are complaining about the
most especially when you start looking
at the plastic lenses on the front of
vehicles it can be hundreds and hundreds
I mean I had a plastic lens on the front
of my Dodge pickup on a fog light was
$300 I mean it's it's crazy stuff and I
don't need a fog light but the
inspection rule said if it came from the
factory it's got to work so any these
are the things that we're trying to look
at representative Hill
thank you um I'm looking at line two on
page three and and it talks about
projection um lower a minimum light
output lower than the original equipment
to me there is and maybe it's just my
age but to me there is a huge range in
the brightness of some some of this the
light uh replacement socket than others
uh or like whatever they call them um so
it would seem to me I don't know how you
ever say that it's lower or higher than
and that's where the complaints for me
come um people complaining that they
can't see with oncoming traffic so
rather than the amount of of um candle
power that comes at me maybe that shows
my age too I don't know um lumens I
guess it is now right um but um it is uh
it would seem to me that that's there's
a there's a wide range we're trying to
narrow down here that is almost
impossible given The Replacements that
are out there but if I can but the bill
just talks about making sure it can't be
lower than Vehicles original equipment I
agree with you some of the aftermarket
ones are too bright they're actually
trying to be regulated currently even in
another build that we have going before
the Senate so okay and with the
different colors too so I agree with you
but this do just says it shouldn't be
lower and I don't think that's a problem
okay um and I'm sure everybody in the
process has been making all kinds of
copious notes so that when we're done
with this it's going to be very quick
for somebody to go over to ol and say we
need to make a change here and a change
here and a change there I'm sure this is
being
done not by me representative
c u this is u a question for the Sergent
is uh I've seen a lot lot of cars uh
that the headlights get hazy on the
front and does anything in here allow
for requiring uh that to be repaired I
know you get polishing kits but seems
like some of the U older Volvos were the
worst on
two line
24 and reading down from there says
every this talks about reflector which
is used as part of a headlight shall
have reflecting surface approved by the
director after satisfactory tests have
been made and every reflecting surface
shall be free of dents and other
imperfections all that talks about the
actual reflection reflective service but
yes um as time goes on with a lot of
these um lights that have a
plastic cover or or the front of the
light itself is PL plastic and it
fades there is
nothing
currently in here that
would that specifically talks
condition
um yeah there is there is nothing in in
here anyways that talks about that now
you could I guess construe U
that to
be
defective um but again we get back to
the sub
subjectivity if that's the right word of
all of us so somebody's going to have to
make a a judgment call as to whether
they feel it's prohibits the proper
operation of it or
not
followup yeah go ahead followup is there
anything in current rules that would uh
deal with that because this isn't this
isn't a uh reflective surface the
reflective surface is on the inside
correct this is the protective outside
surface but it also internally usually
has some lens element molded into
it so yeah the looking at this um on
page two
again it talks about a
motorcycle
there's nothing in here that speaks to
that at all
and to my knowledge of the 3200 rules
which are the inspection rules
um my recollection it just says it has
to properly
function
and having somebody make the the
Judgment call that it was defective
because it
didn't allow enough light come out to
come out would would be again subjective
to the to the inspector that's
performing the inspection so it's
unfortunately as we get further and
further along in a lot of the newer
technology there's a lot of things that
come up that are just not addressed and
that would be one of
them thank
you represent
SES thank you Mr chairman I I want to
actually jump into a slightly different
question so the language about um
vehicle shall not fail inspection if the
windows won't open begs the question for
me
of if there were some type of event
whether it be an accident or uh ending
up on its side so the doors didn't work
I'm I'm just I am a little concerned
about rescue possibilities if the
windows don't work and I understand that
initially obviously when police or fire
arrive they have ways to get the windows
open you using certain tools but what
about the person in the car who needs to
get out and I'm I'm just I I wondered if
you had an opinion about that or and I
and I would ask my colleagues to think
about that
too thank you for the questions sir yes
I I actually was quite surprised to see
that in here um as a first responder I I
do have a a big issue with that
um I don't know of any specific event in
New Hampshire um there was one recently
with a Tesla that went into the water
that ended
up um the driver not surviving someplace
out on the west coast because I couldn't
get a window down
um I don't know the exact circumstance
but that was within the last month so as
far as a first respond goes yeah that
that's a that's an issue that I I think
in my opinion as you asked that's that's
not a that's not something that I would
be in favor
of well from from from what if I can
reply to that for the electric vehicles
that's a problem that's been part of the
conversation is that when the 12vt
system shuts down as part of an issue
with the main batteries that none of the
windows work corre so that's by Design
that's by manufacturer um that's that
particular thing is a problem that we
should be talking to them about yeah um
but in terms of rules right now um I do
understand what the First Responders am
I correct in saying that if a window
won't go up you can get a sticker but if
it won't go down you
can't that's currently currently yes I
think it again thinking back on the 3200
rules I think it says it has to properly
function I don't think it spells out one
way or the other I think it just says it
has to properly function okay thank you
anybody else representative Sellers and
we're only going to do this for a little
bit longer then we're going to make a
decision decision what we want to do
with this bill as a whole um whether
we're going to continue to amend or if
we're going to have a different love the
transportation metaphors a different
route to
take representa sers thank you Mr thank
you Mr chair um a few things uh going
back to page three for a second on lines
uh I guess what is it
34 where it said extensive didn't that
come lot of rules didn't rules have that
in there or is that something that maybe
you uh created on that one issue I'm
just trying to understand because a lot
of this stuff for the breaks I thought
came out of rules and or most all of
it I don't believe that word came out of
rules because the rules actually
mentioned rust as well any rust and it
didn't say how much I mean it could have
been a orange Sheen and somebody could
have failed
it
which is what started us on this
conversation to begin with that's just
not fair or right thank you the my
my I'm sorry one other question go ahead
follow thanks um I'm just
saying a lot of the stuff is is is Right
some of it's definitely sub subjective
but going back to the window pod itself
and what what the chair said I mean your
electric your Electric System it fails
everybody has electric windows this day
so if they fail I mean um you go in
water the 12vt system fails the window
doesn't go up or down anyway so to me
that's just I don't know we're just
trying to get the little Gat out of this
bill and I'm saying we're trying to help
the people that really need help because
they can't afford a three or $400 head
lamp or or $200 tail lamp because it's
cracked yeah it might diffuse the the uh
the beam a little bit but I don't know
how many times that actually happens and
unless we have a out and and we know
that hey this is a problem then I think
we should at least try to help the
people some uh it no bill is not going
to be 100% right no matter what we do
unless we list every single thing on
there so I'm just very concerned to me
it's starting to get uh overwhelming
with maybe all the changes that are
going to need to be done and we're going
to end up throwing a a bill that might
be helpful just throwing the whole thing
away thank you sir I sawar down here
representative belber welcome welome to
Transportation thank you it's a pleasure
to be here I'm always happy to learn um
I grew up in Manhattan and my parents
were very strict about when you're
driving you follow the rules so when I
was a kid and we would pass a No Parking
Zone and there was a car parked in it I
would say to my father or my mom why is
there a car there and my dad would half
jokingly say because it doesn't say
at then so I'm wondering in uh on page
two on line
27 um cracks in a headlamp shall not
cause inspection
failure people I know will try to get
away with things if they
can and even though it is repetitive I
wonder if adding there and then again on
uh line eight on page three repeating
what it says just before that along the
lines of shall not cause inspection
failure unless they inhibit the ability
for the light to blah blah blah and just
even though it's repetitive it's really
clear so if you go to get your car
inspected and there's a crack and you
get a failure notice somebody say but it
says it doesn't matter say yeah except
it inhibits the ability for you to uh to
get proper light coming out of your car
and then if I may uh a question for you
is there any a manual whether paper or
electronic that's sent to inspection
stations so that
they see what the difference between a
well this really is okay and that really
isn't so to answer your question thank
you for the question um no
there is no guidance given it's
basically just whatever is in rule or
law and again it becomes very subjective
um you that's one thing you can't teach
is I guess by experience somebody can
determine whether or not something would
interfere but without uh having
something specifically written or
pictures which are not included in that
um no
so the anybody that does inspections in
New Hampshire has the in-host machine um
other than a a fleet inspection
sometimes um it has all of this
information in it but it doesn't have
pictures that go along with it
no I I just wonder if was there follow
up I'm sorry yes I just wonder
if in some if the directionals don't
work they don't work they they don't
sort of work correct either they do or
they don't but for something where there
is subjectiveness involved I wonder if
it might be worth posting on a the
website or something like that this is
what we mean by this is rust and this is
pitting or the equivalent thank you Mr
chair very good point thank you yeah
that's a another challenge that we have
because we contract to a company called
Gordon Derby so any decisions to either
we make or come out of Jael car then
have to get transmitted to the company
that actually runs the machines and it's
got to get on their software which can
get get transmitt it to all the
inspection stations that's that's a
whole another conversation but last
question in terms of well I see I'm GNA
have to give I'm gonna have to give one
shot for those that haven't on
dissecting this any further
repres thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Steph s taking my question in terms
of the cracked
headlights I know I'm going to show my
age that many years ago when I used to
get my car
inspected um there used to be like
something on the wall so that when they
turned my headlights on the headlights
had to hit a certain area you know on
this wall area which allowed me to pass
inspection with the cracked headlights
um not being added in inspection station
when they turn them on is there do they
test it like that or do they just turn
them on and just see
that that they're working I mean is
there a I guess what I'm asking is is
there
a thing that they test to say yep it hit
this
particular perimeter viewing for it to
pass thank you for the question yes
there is so uh yes
um going back a number of years I won't
say how many um we used the wall the
thing on the wall yeah um nowadays we
have this fancy little machine that
rolls up right up against the headlight
it's a headlight aimer that every
inspection station in the Hamp is
supposed to have and use um that
determines whether or not it actually is
aimed properly so yes uh to your
question there are two ways the screen
that's on the wall which requires a
certain distance y um from the front of
the vehicle to the wall or the headlight
aimer machine that actually rolls right
up against the the vehicle itself so yes
those two methods um one or the other
has to be used and yes um if for some
reason the headlight was damaged and did
not project properly it would show up
when they tested it if that makes sense
to you can follow follow
so if you mentioned that when there's a
crack on the sides the the light can be
distorted a little bit so in this in
these tests would it pick that up that
it gets distorted
incorrectly it would it would pick it up
if it affected the actual projection of
it so it wasn't projected properly yes
but as far as light for the lack of
better term escaping someplace else it
would not thank you
representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
step for being here
um mine's an easy question I just want
to ask if the two sections on uh in one
on page two one on page three one about
head head lamps and tail lamps we were
talking about tape which isn't in there
but the word tape is very generalized
should it be if we do put tape in there
shouldn't be like color matching
translucent tape we don't want duct tape
over a a
lens thank you for the question that's
absolutely correct sir that would be the
language that the suggested language
that would be in there so it would
clarify correct you can't put black
fun some things never SE to amaz all
right um I'm not even sure how to do
this yeah
absolutely do we want to attempt well
first of all I think everybody in the
room wants to do
something so the next question would be
because we have options on how this
plans out today we could
theoretically take the some of the
highlighted issues that we had today and
get it re amended we have all day I can
recess our EX excutive session and take
it up even after our public hearings
this afternoon if we want to do
something um we could pass it the way it
is or we could itl
it um end of the day this is kind of
frustrating only because if I'm a firm
believer if we don't do something in
terms of people are not hating this as
much as they do the solution that we're
looking for is going to mean we don't
have the program at all it's one of
these days it's going to happen so I'll
leave it at that um let me speak with
the ranking member for a moment we'll
probably go into a caucus to
decide um to which which which direction
minute
okay so we are going to caucus can we
meet in your office or is that a problem
we are going to caucus so if I can have
the Republican stay in this room
and if I can have members of the public
you
e
me
okay welcome back everybody um to make
it official I don't remember actually
closing our work session so I'll close
our work
session actually I will open up the for
give me a minute that to get up to speed
but I will be opening up the executive
session on host Bill 1273 FN relative to
the protection of personal information
in driver
licenses and I'll wait for the clerk to
light okay again the uh executive
session is open on House Bill 1273 chair
recogniz is representative sellers for a
motion thank you Mr chair a motion on HP
1273 uh as an interim
study motion is interim study is there a
second I'll second second by
representative Crawford care to speak
your motion sir sure thank you Mr chair
and uh we could actually talk about this
for the next two or three hours if you
like however and uh and my apology to uh
uh representative syes I I really
thought we could find some solutions
here and my god when we started diving
into this and it was like we just came
up with more problems but we all agree
our privacy is really really important
but so let's go to a study and let's see
what we can figure
out I thank you for that and I concur uh
it wasn't for the lack of trying we're
just up against the deadline um and so
we did look at it one more time since
our last executive session and more
questions arose so uh to give it a fair
Shake uh this is not a death With
Dignity interim study this will be a
real interim study there always next
year anybody else from the
committee represent SES yeah I would be
in support of this motion for interim
study I think that um all the reasons
elucidated with great eloquence by
representative sellers is true that
there are a lot of questions here and we
need to work on this if we're going to
pass good
law anybody else seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call the role the motion is
in R stud on House Bill
1273 Vice chairman Gorski
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative
D yes representative foot yes
representative C yes representative cers
yes representative gagy yes
representative Sykes
yes representative Rich yes
representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
veu yes representative Jones yes
representative pandon yes representative
Jack yes representative elberger yes
yes
19 oh 19 that's right no because no Ste
19 to zero uh so our recommendation of
interim study is adopted 19 to zero um
the prime sponsor did ask if we could
put this on on regular calendar just so
we could make State make a few
statements about it I did let him know
that it was um going to be interum
studied and he said that's fine but if
he just asked if we could leave it on
the calendar so if that's okay with
everybody we will do that saves him from
pulling it uh so I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
please
okay well now I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
1637 relative to reducing requirements
for vehicle
inspections uh in talks with uh all of
my colleagues in the ranking member it
does look like we might be able to come
to some consensus with a few Corrections
based on our work session this morning
so to accomplish that I'm going to
recess the executive session until after
our public hearings this afternoon so as
soon as our hearings are done uh we'll
go back into executive session the
changes are slight so I'm hopeful we'll
be able to get the amendment back by
from OS by then so again I'm going to
recess the executive session on House
Bill
sorry and now we do have U Senate bills
being heard at 1:00 this afternoon again
we'll do the uh executive session after
complete
e
for
well good afternoon we are going to
officially open up the uh public hearing
on SB
429 relative to the color of executive
Council official cover plates the chair
I like to recognize uh Denise ricardi
the prime sponsor of the bill Denise
welcome to the house version of
Transportation uh thank you uh good
afternoon chairman Gorski and members of
the House Transportation committee it's
nice to see all of you uh for the record
I'm Denise rardy I'm the state senator
for District 9 uh representing Bedford
and uh 12 other vibrant
towns um I'm honored to address you
today in support of Senate Bill
429 concerning Governor's coun plates
Senate Bill 429 would allow executive
Council plates to be printed with blue
numbers and letters on white background
exclusively as it has been previously in
the case for many many years however
during the legislative plate production
and issuance that occurred in 2023 the
Division of Motor Vehicles followed the
state law RSA
261 semicolon 90 which requires all the
legislative plates to be printed with
green or red numbers and letters which
should alternate every B anyia this bill
seeks to bring consistency back to the
issuance of the executive Council plates
by allowing them to be printed
exclusively with blue numbers and
letters on a white background as has
been the case for many years by aligning
with historical practice Senate Bill 429
ensures uniformity in the design of
these plates and eliminates confusion
among motorists and law enforcement
agencies in conclusion Senate Bill 429
is a common sense measure that will
address an oversight in the plate
production while upholding the
historical and symbolic significance of
the executive Council plates I ask the
members of this committee to please
support the bill and ensure its passage
for the benefit of our state and thank
you for your attention in this matter if
you have any questions I'd be have happy
to answer
them okay thank you so much any
questions from the
committee representative
sellers thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my question I don't see a cost on
this is there any additional cost and
and we we're only talking five plates
right yes any additional cost are you
no
any no I believe there's no additional
cost there's not I just wanted to
confirm that um it just was an oversight
and the executive Council was used to
having that same plate but then you know
being rule followers that we are we we
realized that in the RSA so um look at
it this way makes our executive Council
happy any other questions from the
committee representative sellers yeah
thank you again um do they have a plate
now yes but it's just not a certain
color well they wanted to stay the way
it always was which was the blue and the
white and now they have been due to this
RSA had to go to what we all have which
is you know alternating the red and the
green and they just want to remain the
was any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you I've got to go chare Transportation
see you later
chair i' like to recognize um executive
counselor Dave wheeler uh who supports
welcome thank you Mr chairman and and
members of the committee um good
afternoon and uh I guess I'll stop by
answering the representative's question
you can see in
2021 uh we had the traditional Blue
Plate and the director became aware of
the statute for this term and realized
that our plates should be green like
yours uh under the law so this term we
have green plates but for the last
decades here's my here's my license
plate from 2002 uh and you can see that
they're blue and we've been blue as long
as I can remember uh previous counselors
before me so we we're simply asking if
you could uh correct the law so we can
continue our long-standing uh tradition
of having uh the blue plates somehow
along the line um we were we didn't stay
aligned with the statute but we'd like
to get that corrected and um ask that
you pass this
bill be happy to answer any
questions thank you any questions from
the
you chair now like to recognize
uh John
morasco who supports the bill who is
looking for five minutes welcome
sir thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh John morasco director of
the DMV um just I would Echo everything
that Senator richardi has testified to
and councel Wheeler like to thank uh
senator richardi for bringing this bill
forth and for councelor wheeler for um
uh having the conversation to get to
this Point um we support the bill there
is uh we did check with the plate room
at the state prison there's no increased
cost by doing this and um as both the
senator and the counselor spoke to we
did follow RSA
26190 which um you know does identify
the fact that every two years the plate
should change from green to red and and
that way um so we followed the law but
in doing that that um did have a little
bit of a a wrinkle here with this
particular plate so we fully support the
change and I'm happy to take any
questions
committee
representative thank you I'm not sure if
the question is for you or for you
um I'm guessing and I just like
confirmation that the reason that the
legislator's plates change is to make it
easy for say people at the garage to say
you were not you were last term you're
not this term is that that
correct you know that's a great question
I don't know the answer to it I can I
can get you an answer to that I I know
what the RSA reads and the fact that
those changes have to take place but let
me let me look into that I'm not sure I
there there are dates on those plates
aren't there
yes so um I I'm just wondering why
anybody needs to change the color of the
plates if the dates are on them already
thank
you someone wants to answer this the
representative
question
present as I recall um and George May or
representative syes may have a bet I
think it had to do with the ability to
get into the parks and the boat Ducks
and the other and and so the colors
mattered from year to year so someone
wouldn't just have um a red plate and
think that they could um have their Bo
they were current no one was looking at
the actual date of the plate that was my
recall okay I can do some research on
that as well to to confirm and
representa question thank you uh would
you agree with me that this code section
was amended in 2019 in the budget uh
about an unrelated matter and that is
when the sentence about the blue was uh
appears to be lost during duee to a
drafting error I don't know the answer
to that sir in 2019 I don't
know I don't know off
hand any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you sir with that I have nobody else
who's uh testifying on this bill so I'm
going to close the hearing on SB
429 our next hearing is uh HB SB 467
minutes
e
thank
you direct I think you should
kid
okay being uh 122 I'd like to open up
the public hearing on SB
467 authorizing the injury prevention
center to issue motor vehicle decal
plates chair i' like to recognize
Senator sue prentis the sponsor of the
bill Senator welcome to Transportation
thank you very much chair and members of
house Transportation it's a great to be
with you this afternoon this is oh
representative Phil long time no see um
this is the first bill the session that
I am introducing over in the house so um
good to see you all this afternoon um as
your chair said my name is Su Prentice
I'm state senator from District 5 I
cover 15 communities including a large
part of Grafton County a portion of
Selvin County and one town in marac the
beautiful new beautiful town of New
London um I am here today in introducing
this bill um because I have a vested
interest in preventing injuries in New
Hampshire preventing injuries that cause
disabilities impacting quality of life
as well as death and although this is a
transportation committee I'm just going
to talk to you a little bit about injury
and why it's such a problem and then
take you to why this could be one
solution that could help us actually
expand our programs outside of the tight
braided funding that already comes to
the state of New Hampshire so some of
you might know but some of you that
don't by way of background I'm a
paramedic and I've worked in the
development and implementation of
systems of care specifically trauma
systems since
1999 um so these systems of care take
into account a continuum so that makes
up that's um parts that make up a whole
from preventing injuries to empowering
the survivors and the road to
Rehabilitation not just physical
rehabilitation but healing the emotional
wounds from injury on the other side and
everything in between which are
ambulances helicopters Trauma Center
Care this is these are systems of care
um that we support and preventing
injuries means two things one we can
save lives and two the folks that are
injured and do survive we can actually
cut down their cost related to their
care and ultimately cost it could be Rel
that can be associated with with Society
so let's talk a little bit more about
this um but before I start I do want to
take a moment to honor somebody that you
all um that you some of you might know
some of you might not know her name is
Elaine Frank Elaine Frank was the
director of the injury prevention center
at Dartmouth for
oh in since the 90s and I actually got
to know her in 1992 when I worked on a
project at the medical school and we
were friends up until the day of her
passing in
2023 she sat in this chair many times
and in other chairs throughout the lob
and the State House advocating on behalf
of programs that would you know save
lives and that would reduce injuries I
worked with her and watched her effort
to improve the lives of granite Staters
through her prevention work never tiring
she was the best listener planner and
ultimately
collaborator she knew how to bring
people together around prevention and
I'm honored to have known her and to
call her my friend and I dedicate this
work to a lame Frank with that being
said uh we are what we would like to see
pass is the Authority for us to issue a
decal plate that would be the funds that
the revenue that was associated with
that would become would be would go to
the injury prevention center at
Dartmouth so they could expand their
current programming which I have some
information on the Department of Health
and Human Service Health and Human
Services has some information on as well
so the again this is about preventing
injuries supporting programs Statewide
and ultim through the injury prevention
center this should be a dedicated sour
source to build out current and future
efforts and we actually have a 5-year
injury prevention plan so every 5 years
we issue a new plan 20125 the current
plan will be up the current plan which
you can access on the HHS website says
injuries whether intentional or
unintentional make a substantial
physical emotional and economic impacts
on society that can have lasting
consequences in 2018 there were
1277 injury related death in New
Hampshire affecting families schools and
workplaces and communities the Fatal
injuries cost over 1 billion in a
lifetime of medical expenses and work
lost which translates into
$771 per capita in New Hampshire so in
2025 we'll have an updated report and
we'll see those numbers be updated U and
I think what we know when from watching
the news is that the one thing which is
you know motor vehicle crashes
motorcycle crashes and now we even have
the introduction of you know some of the
electronic devices scooters and such
we're still seeing injuries and death
not level off but actually um take a
rise I pull the majority of my data
besides what I just shared with you from
DHHS from the Centers for Disease
Control specifically their whiskers
database this is publicly available you
can um you can actually change the ages
and the types of things that you're
looking for so you can like more qualify
and specify your data so here's what the
CDC says about New Hampshire injury
Remains the leading cause of death
between the ages of 1 and 44 in New
Hampshire occupies High rates of
hospitalizations in beds more often than
cancer heart disease and AIDS combined
the costs to individuals their families
and back to society are staggering and
yet this is
preventable you know I've been in my
work I've been thinking about this for
years and we know that the burden of
injury it's not often talked about and I
feel like sometimes it's a little bit of
Groundhog Day and I wish Dr Patterson
Lisa Patterson who's the head of the
trauma program at conquered hospital was
able to join us today uh because she
points out um something that I've always
carried with me is that I can I have
this conversation about how this is a
leading cause of death for really the
young okay and that it is it goes Rel
Rel atively unnoticed until we have
these kinds of conversations it's not
for lack of trying but it's so episodic
you don't leave your house
expecting to unfortunately be in a crash
you don't leave your house expecting to
take a fall like things happen but we
have mechanisms we can put in place that
can prevent some of these things from
happening and I actually want to point
over to my colleague from Lebanon U just
for a moment talk a little bit about
fire prevention vention that if we've
learned anything we've learned from the
fire prevention community that we have
pushed down the numbers we've dropped
the numbers of building fires because of
the focus on fire prevention and the
fire departments for the building fires
that they have they do an incredible job
but many of them and they proudly will
say it are providing Emergency Medical
Services because people are still
getting hurt and people are still sick
so we can follow in the footsteps of the
great work of Fire prevention in doing
our injury prevention work on this side
as well and this is something that has
happened Nationwide so this proposed
Bill brings forward a new um new but not
new to injury source of funding and by
choice for our Granite Staters so they
would choose that they want to purchase
a decal plate and they want to choose
and the injury prevention decal in
particular it will raise a level of
awareness around injury and again it
will provide some well-needed Revenue
that we can actually expand the numbers
and types of programs that are made
available um so with that um I have Abby
Rogers from DHHS here because I can talk
about the way that funding is structured
right now unfortunately Dr Patterson
could not join us today but she would
say um and it's in the Senate hearing
report she would talk about just what I
did in terms of how many lives are lost
to this the age groups of them and that
this is just it's relatively it comes
it's it's relatively silent until it is
literally on your doorstep and we know
that we can prevent injuries I will wrap
up here I'm certainly um happy to take
any questions that you might have but I
I want to point out that in all of the
AED boxes around these buil in the lob
we have uh boxes for automatic external
defibrillators we have them over in the
state house and now we actually passed a
law last year that puts these that puts
turnic kits which are now in those boxes
in hight TR state buildings that there's
a pro you don't have to be trained to
use those but if you wanted to learn
more you could take a stop the bleed
program okay and this would help do that
so we are taking steps as a legislature
and you know very deliberatively to try
to reduce injuries and death related to
injuries by putting tourniquets in with
our aeds and making them available so I
will wrap with that and do my best to
answer any questions that you might have
and I do
appreciate um your time today and I have
a I've been given a a prop to you know
to show I think you're all familiar with
these so Mr chair thank you and I'll let
you direct question then thank you so
much Senator any questions from the
Hill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator for coming and visiting us today
um I just have one question luckily I'm
outside that 1 to 44 four range so I
don't have to worry about injury but um
too I I was uh aside from Charlie I
think we're all set um uh the I'm I'm
curious about the fact that the funding
would only go to Dartmouth um is that
did I hear that correctly and why would
that be thank you for your question um
so the way it is structured and I'm
going to have Abby talk to this is there
are funds that come into the state of
New Hampshire that support injury
prevention
and then those funds through a
competitive RFP process okay are set
aside and they search for an injury
prevention center and I remember
actually when I worked in state
government I was on the Review Committee
for the injury prevention center so
these are awarded to Dartmouth like they
could be awarded to anybody that
actually met the requirements that were
put forward so that's why it goes there
okay so it is not that we are supporting
Dartmouth directly they are the
deliverer of injury prevention programs
by way of a contract that is funded
through HHS a competitive process you're
welcome representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman so um I was
pleased to hear you talk about Elaine
Frank um she also was a friend of mine
we we uh had a long history together of
trying to make a difference in the world
starting with um for my colleagues
benefit something called uh slip stps
and Falls avoid them all kind of program
we did that at Rogers house together
yeah we did that at Rogers house which
was an elderly housing facility and it
made a difference and it actually
continued to make a difference what I
what I think one of the messages I would
like the committee to hear about is that
these little steps that don't seem all
that significant um they have a way of
morphing into bigger and better ways to
deal with common problems and that's why
now uh Progressive fire departments are
doing uh Community nursing programs
they're doing uh they're getting they're
having paramedics who go into the home
to try and um help people with avoiding
or working on their health issues uh
something that I'm very familiar with
recently so I think anything that this
legislature could do I I my question is
I assume that you would be in support of
getting this message out as much as
possible
so thank you for the comment and our
shared love of Elaine Frank um and I and
your the answer to your question is
anything we can do and I believe I said
this in the in the very early part of my
introduction is it would provide a
revenue Source a dedicated Revenue
Source by choice okay so if somebody
wants to make this purchase they can but
I also think the benefit of this is
raising the level of the conversation
around how important preventing injury
is and how prevalent injury is in our
society and although I focused in on the
one through
44 let's you know I can't leave this
table without saying that when you start
to qualify the data on over
55 what we find so the 1 through 44 is a
lot of Motor Vehicle crashes or
motorcycle crashes you know pedestrian
but when we start to talk about Falls
anything we can do to prevent Falls over
55 we can actually save a life within a
year greater than the age of 55 with
even one medical condition and a fall
which may seem simple could morph itself
into something that becomes you know
ultimately deadly so I focused in on the
youth well that you know uh but this
really impacts
everybody thank you any other questions
from the committee representative
pemon thank you Mr chair thank you
Senator my question is on the example of
the plate the sticker plate um what
would we would we be looking at a blue
sticker or will it be something that
says drive safely avoid slips and Falls
would it be something of the message on
the plate so thank you representative
and thank you for the question so it
will be ultimately up to the
commissioner of the Department of Safety
to take the input and design what would
fit in a small space that could then
become universally recognized ized
so injury prevention covers
crashes
Falls um it actually can cover acts of
violence as well so I'm not I don't know
what it will be but I trust that the
commissioner like commissioners before
them have worked to come up with designs
that can fit here and make a statement
um and would obviously we would
cooperate and uh be cheerleaders in
that any other questions from the
not seeing any thank you Senator thank
you so much chair i' like to now
recognize Abby Rogers from
DHHS who is requesting two minutes and
has some written testimony that she'll
be passing
around
welcome good afternoon uh my name is
Abby Rogers I'm the legislative Leon for
the division of Public Health Services
um I am sitting in for my colleague
Ronda seagull this morning uh this
afternoon to provide test Ronda is the
overseas the injury prevention program
at DHHS I want to thank Senator
Apprentice for bringing this bill
forward um uh here today provide
information around on S SP 467
authorizing injury prevention center to
issue um motor vehicle detail uh decal
plates uh Senator Apprentice mentioned
unintentional injuries such as Trauma
from car crashes or unint unintentional
overdose is a leading cause of death in
New Hampshire for the age uh age group
44 and under an individual's injury risk
uh is related to the level of C
cognitive physical um and Social
Development uh thus adolescent children
and older adults are more susceptible to
death and disability from injury the
dphs injury prevention program works
with Community Partners such as
Dartmouth Health injury prevention
center to reduce these preventable
deaths and disabilities currently the
funding for DHHS which Senator appren
just referenced injury prevention
programs contract is with Dartmouth
health injury prevention center and it
comes primarily through the source of
federal funds Health Resources and
services
Administration um specifically through
the Maternal Child Health Title 5 block
grant and the CDC uh Centers for Disease
controls pre and prevention as well as a
prevented of Health Services Federal
block grants um these Federal resources
are super important to support support
our data collection analysis and
Community Based prevention strategies at
uh that that are done through Dartmouth
Health uh injury convention center and
all of the efforts that DHHS works on in
coordination with other partners are
designed to provote effective Public
Health uh solutions to injury and
prevent harm in the first place um
contractual activities to support the
program follow the New Hampshire
violence and injury prevention state
plan which is 2020 through 2025 so a
five-year block grant um and just
basically we're here to say that if if
the bill was enacted we would this would
enable the injury prevention center to
increase its capacity for implementing
important community- based interventions
to uh prevent injury so that's my
testimony and we again thank Senator
Apprentice for bringing the bill
forward thank you so much any questions
from the committee representative
Hill uh thank you and thank you for
taking my question um who is going to
pay the uh the cost of this upfront um
the there is a typical I think it's
actually even on the bill a $10,000 cost
for the initial um
outlay the outlay I'm not I'm not sure I
I don't think it's our department
um okay yeah sorry it's not the HHS and
I don't believe it comes out of our
block grant okay thank you sure
representative sers thank you Mr
chair um is this program fully funded
now and is this the the decal is only
for getting more people to aware or is
it are you trying to raise money to help
fund this program so my understanding is
the decal serves two purposes as other
um organizations that are in the decal
program right to raise awareness of an
important cause and certainly this is a
very important cause preventing injury
prevention um and I'm sorry what was the
second part of your
question is it is the program fully
funded now oh fully funded well so we
work with the we we have Federal
resources that come in that we contract
with dart meth this would be additional
Revenue which would be put toward um
injury prevention programs and
activities
followup yeah thank
you could you list some of those
activities so I get an idea what you're
trying to use the money
for sure I can ask Senator Apprentice to
join me
may I have a I have a list here
um so and this would be to expand they
are limited on the programs that they
can deliver because there's only so much
money that comes through these Grant
programs that is available so helmet and
bike and pedest and safety program stop
the bleed programs bicycle lights which
is also a you know bicycle safety
program for children um it would support
safe kit so there's Safe kitss program
in New Hampshire which does work again
around motor vehicles around bicycles
and around pedestrian related activities
there's a life jacket loner program that
right now 21 communities have adopted
but they could expand the number of
communities to prevent drowning by
having these looners available so they
have them in 200 they only have 207 that
are loaned out to these 21 communities
that could be expanded the youth
operator program contracted by The
Matrix save the life tour that sponsors
simulation events in high schools really
around thinking fast when operating
motor vehicles and enhancing the
continued work of the child passenger
safety program so making sure that the
child seats that we the child seats that
infants
toddlers are put in are installed
correctly by training the technicians
and often times we see that um not just
out see them at local fire departments
will become trained to do this so they
can do it in their communities but we
see nurses and folks that work at Birth
at maternity units of birth and Care
Centers so those are just some of the
programs uh that are have limited
funding but are doing a great job right
now we could actually help them by
available any other questions for the
Comm representative pemon thank you Mr
chair and thank you to both of you um if
this reference is black grant money so
how were these funds applied for are
they applied uh by municipalities for
these funds or through medical
facilities how are they allocated uh
sure so our block grant is something
that it's a federal block grant and the
department submits um you know
information through Grant applications
to receive the funds to the federal
government based on our priorities and
what we see a need is here in New
Hampshire for those funds okay how if I
could continue follow up how are they uh
allocated throughout New Hampshire
specifically who is it the
municipalities that would reach out to
Dartmouth to say we've got a lifesaver
program or life jacket program for
rental how how are they allocated right
so the department receives money from
the federal government for injury
prevention and the department would
allocate some of those Grant funds based
on needs in the community and those and
those programs that are that are
identified as needing funds
okay I'm just trying to get an answer
additional follow so in other words if I
understand you correctly the M the
municipalities would be let say the city
of nashor would reach out to you they
could and that that's and then they
would be allocated Accord to there and
then I don't know if that the senator
knows that the question that was asked
earlier about the fiscal impact of the
$10,000 where that's coming from
so how of Senate Finance we pass
and there was no fiscal note there was a
discussion of $10,000 but then there was
discussion about there being no fiscal
note I believe that that would I'd have
to turn to director morasco on that okay
thank you thank you Mr and he has he has
he'll be coming up to testify in a
moment thank you I had an additional
comment if I could so um Senator
Apprentice mentioned the life jacket
laner stations that would be available
to be funded through this and I do want
to make the commit do want to make the
committee aware that there was a life
jaer laner bill that was heard in
Recreation and resources to set up a
life jacket loader station along the
marac River due to the increased amount
of drownings um that bill was not found
uh would did not pass due to logistical
issues but just did want to share that
that was life jackets and drownings were
um specifically mentioned in the child
fatality review report that the
department does on child like untimely
child deaths and so this is a priority
uh that this funds would go to some like
something like that which is identified
as an issue so so just wanted to share
that just we were just in there
testifying on that Bill thank you
representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
to you both for being here um I just
want to know does having the legislation
approve this does that help you is that
like a star in your application when
you're do applying for a block rant is
that good to show that you have the
support of the legislation um I would
say that so I'm not the program
administrator I would say that it it's
recognition in a Grant application that
the legislators heard our concerns and
that injury prevention is a
priority
sure representative sers thank you Mr
chair um how much does the program bring
in now from the federal government or
all funds does the state provide any to
feds the towns you as I said I I don't
have that figure off hand I can get that
for you um from the program
administrator on the absolute the
amount thank you yeah thank you any
further questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you so
much chairman i' like to recognize uh
John morasco who is in support of the
bill representative of morasco good to
see you
again thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I appreciate the opportunity
to speak um we do support the bill um I
had conversations with Senator
Apprentice early on uh regarding what
she was trying to do with the bill and
uh for the injury pres prevention center
um and as far as the fiscal portion of
it goes so uh as far as the DMV is
concerned it's it's $8 for a pair of
plates um that's what our role is when a
decal is created and it comes to the DMV
after approved by the legislature uh we
do look at the decal U to make sure that
the reflectivity is appropriate um that
the sizing is correct um but as far as
what that decal is going to look like um
that's something that the nonprofit
would work on and then deliver it to us
so that's our role in it our role is
really to
produce this um with a perforated box
here for where the legislatively
approved decal will go um and just to uh
look at the decals before they're
actually put into motion by the
nonprofit so for us there's no fiscal
impact we produce these plates we're
going to continue to produce them with
the perforated box and it's up to the
nonprofit to come up with the the decal
make sure that it meets the proper specs
and then the money that goes back into
forth um to issue the decal and the
money that comes in um through the
consumer we don't get involved with that
part thank you any questions from the
committee representative
stclair thank you Mr chair and thank you
um so we're talking zero or a lot less
than $10,000 so the $10,000 I'm trying
to get an answer on I don't know exactly
how the $110,000 fits in with the DMV I
from supervisors and registration it's
the $8 to produce the plate that the
prison already produces for us with the
perforated box so I'm not quite sure
where the 8ou the $10,000 comes in I
don't know nor do I thank you thank you
any other questions from the
committee representative sers I just
have a a comment to uh representative St
Clair we did the same thing on the
veterans plate and they put a
$10,000 price tag on
it there
guesstimate yeah any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you sir thank you Mr
chairman okay CH I'd like to recognize
Angie
lul who is in support of the bill asking
for five minutes and she's representing
welcome thank you means go in this state
okay all right thank you so much my
apology
uh for being late I was in the wrong
location I'm Angela Duke I'm the manager
of the injury prevention center at
Dartmouth health located in Lebanon and
I understand that Senator Apprentice had
already given testimony so I definitely
don't need five minutes um but I'm here
just in support of SB um
467 and available to answer any
questions this uh additional funding
from the license plate would definitely
supplement and and allow us to expand
our programs currently we have um
reduced funding this particular fiscal
year for our community programs so for
example we've been able to
um in the last couple of years fund 40
to 60 New Hampshire communities with
bike helmets and bike and pedestrian
pedestrian safety information
information and education um
unfortunately this year with reduced
funding with some supplemental from
dmouth Heth
we're now down to just um being able to
award 30 communities so this would allow
us to uh continue to grow that program
and we do prioritize new communities and
try to honor um previously awarded
communities as much as possible and the
bik helments go along with um not just
the education but um municipalities
police departments other Town um
organizations will uh set up bike rodeos
um where they will hand out disseminate
the the helmets and the information and
they do helmet fitting so it really is a
pretty expansive opportunity um we have
recently been able to address the life
jacket laner program um and each year we
try to increase the number of
communities served um there was an
increase in drownings last year and so
we are trying to increase our life
jacket loaner program this year we'll be
able to fund um 20 additional
communities but we're not sure where the
funding will will come from for the next
couple of years so this is an
opportunity to ensure that we can um
continue these really important programs
and continue to reduce injury across the
state thank you any questions from the
committee representative
Fox thank you Mr chairman who do you
anticipate would purchase these decal
and and how much do you
anticipate um um you will you will
benefit um we have a pretty vast
Statewide network of um both um
nonprofit organizations but um education
we know we have some stakeholders that
would definitely invest in this so we
trust um that would go far and wide
there's a lot of injury prevention
Professionals in the state um and
whether they are state funded or not I
think that they would be willing to
support this and help share this with
their networks we do a lot of work in
many different areas of injury
prevention so we have pretty strong
stakeholder list um I'm not sure how
much this would bring in this is a
program that's completely new to me I
don't know if Senator Apprentice has um
additional information on that so follow
up follow up please and I'm not sure if
addressing the question to you how much
um how much will you charge for the
decal or how much is do the other
organiz ation
charge I'm not
sure I can speak I I imagine that um or
a trust that U representative sellers
can speak to the veterans L do you know
the cost of that I know the um organ
donation okay so would it be okay if
would you mind sharing that
information the only information I had
was the cost I don't know what they
charge okay oh all right sorry I um just
you'd had experience with it so um
the New England the Oregon bank has a
decal plate and they charge $30 on top
of the 15 so the 15 that goes to the
Department of Motor Vehicles and the 30
that goes towards their program and
there's if you go to the DMV website you
can see a list it's not a lot uh but you
can see a list of the different programs
you can click on it you can see their
decal you can see what they charge thank
you you're welcome any further questions
from the committee representative
pemon thank you Mr chair in in um
listening to the testimony um apparently
the federal block grant monies are what
have you you've been relying on lately
uh in my experience uh Federal block
grants are not guaranteed funds um if my
first question if I may ask have you
noticed a downward Trend in the federal
assistance yes so we do um have
Dartmouth Health dollars as well that
but the majority of our Dartmouth Health
dollars are serving the injury
prevention needs of our providers and
patient patients um although we do have
some monies that allow us to support our
some of our community based programs so
we have relied more heavily on the state
block grant dollars to help support the
community based programs and yes I would
say that we have seen a a downward Trend
so we're probably uh losing about 30,000
on average a year for our community-
based programs thank followup followup
so in other words uh uh if this passes
this would be of of not just
supplemental monies but really needed
Monies to continue the program am I
correct yes correct I mean as we as we
know block grant dollars are not
guaranteed so they're always a little
bit um variable anyway so this would be
definitely a more stable funding stream
one more followup one more followup um
should this pass how do you plan on
getting the communications out to the
municipality within New Hampshire yeah
as I mentioned before we have a strong
Communications with our um all of our
stakeholders we also utilize um our
state departments so the New Hampshire
office of Highway Safety and the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services to help us share the
information we also utilize Dartmouth
Health Communications and marketing team
um to help us with with this kind of
effort as
well any further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you that I have no other
cards so at this point I'm going to
close the hearing on SB
467 we'll be starting up SB 465 just
so
e
okay with it being uh 154 I'm going to
start the public hearing on S SP
465 relative to motorist duties When
approaching Highway emergencies
involving a stopped or standing vehic
and the chair would like to recognize
Senator Fenton Senator it's great to see
you back in transportation it's good to
be home you
know thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record I am
Senator Donovan Fenton and represent
district 10 I'm here to talk to you
about Senate Bill 465 relative to
motorist duties When approaching Highway
emergency vehicles involving a disabled
vehicle the current Move Over law in New
Hampshire applies to vehicles displaying
red blue Amber emergency or warning
lights but cable 465 will expand this
law to cover disabled Vehicles as well
this Bill calls for action for motorists
When approaching a disabled vehicle
along the roadside and adds the term
disabled vehicle and provides a
definition to RSA 265
37a this bill requires vehicle operators
with due consideration to safety and
traffic conditions to move over safely
if impossible or unsafe vehicle
operators may pass a disabled vehicle at
a careful speed according to the New
Hampshire highway traffic safety
administration 350 motorists are struck
and killed each year uh while outside
their vehicle currently 20 states have
similar laws uh simil uh the New
Hampshire committee the National
Committee on traffic laws and ordinances
along with the national highway traffic
safety administration and National
Council of state legislators at the
mouthful I apologize published the
incident responders safety model law
this model this model law removed
language regarding specific vehicles to
include all vehicles and people When
approaching a roadside incident
similarly the intent of Senate Bill 465
is to standardize the necessary practice
of slowing down and moving over for all
vehicles that are on the roadside both
working and disabled and with that I am
happy to take any
questions thank you Senator any
questions from the
committee representative Hill yes I just
wanted to thank the senator for
providing a role model for we
Transportation people yeah it's only up
from here
guys um I just want I do have a question
about um
um how would this be enforced um if a if
a vehicle is by the side of the road and
it's um unclear to the person
approaching whether it's disabled or not
absolutely and we thank you for the
question representative we had those
discussions you know what is a disabled
vehicle and so we came to the conclusion
that essentially any car on the side of
the road could be considered uh disabled
and is there anyone with a badge behind
there's a couple guys with badges behind
me so they could probably tell you how
they're going to enforce it but you know
I think the reality is that you know
we're not necessarily looking to punish
people we're looking for people to be
safe and um you know a young gentleman
was struck and killed recently a 24 year
old um because he was just changing his
tire and I think if we all know that we
have to move over for any vehicle on the
side of the road I think that would um
save a lot of
casualties thanks yeah any other
questions from the committee
representative
plemon
claric flashing light from a vehicle
instead of you know the red blue and
Amber emergency vehicle when it stated
warning lights is that the intention
here representative thank you for the
question I don't have a full description
on what warning lights are um these
gentlemen might I hope I keep relying on
them but I think it's um you know only
certain individuals organizations are
allowed to have warning lights on their
vehicle could be a snowplow uh tow truck
which mostly is Amber lights or it could
be those bright white lights they're on
the back of Troopers
Vehicles representative we do have New
Hampshire State Police who will be
testifying as well um as well okay any
other questions from the committee
representative Rambo it's sort of a
question comment prior to comments and
maybe we'll get clarified by the next
point the language we suggests don't
need any of those lights any stopped or
standing vehicle would be reason to give
birth so b rth um so it would not be
necessarily contingent on any of the the
warning lights or whether the vehicle's
disabled for based on this language
correct and that's correct I think um
you know I think we still want that
language in there just so people
understand like you still have to move
over for everything it's not exclusive
other
correct any other questions from the
committee representative sellers thank
you Mr chair um so going down a double
lane Highway here do I have to move over
to the highp speed lane from the slow so
away from the breakdown Lane is that
what you're envisioning as well I
appreciate the question representative
it's um what you can do safely you know
we're not looking to cause another
accident it's um you know if you can't
move over you can't move over and you're
not going to get penalized for
that any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
Senator thank you very much with that
the chair I like to recognize
Matthew matio hopefully I said said that
right from New Hampshire State Police
who supports the bill uh who's looking
for one minute welcome
sir thank you
sir yes my name is Matthew Uchi and I'm
a captain with the New Hampshire State
Police uh we are in support of this bill
uh the Move Over Law should be expanded
to include all vehicles not just
emergency vehicles all drivers should be
required to move over or slow down to
answer your question sir
um When approaching any vehicle stopped
on the side of the road for any
reason uh the expansion would enhance
the safety of all individuals including
workers um it would create a culture of
Greater awareness
uh and reduce the risk of accidents and
injuries that's the the objective of
this is to create awareness the vast
majority of drivers are law abiding
citizens this is just to create that
awareness um so that when you do see a
vehicle that is stopped or parked on the
side of the roadway and you have the
ability to to slow down and move over
you do so safely uh the Move Over Law
should be inclusive and protect all
individuals who may find themselves on
the side of the road for various
reasons thank you Sarah any questions
committee representative Hill
thank you uh Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question are there any
numbers or any in um ideas of incidents
I have been on 93 and someone and not
known that someone was pulled off to the
side but the person in the uh traveling
Lane thought it was important for them
to move over into my lane and almost
sent me into um the southp lane um is
there have we noticed any kind of
incidents of of accidents due to the
Move Over law that uh that um people
immediately very good question uh I
don't have a an answer on okay data or
statistics on that um what would be
messaged is to to safely slow down first
and then move over if if you can um and
we want to avoid unintended consequences
which on if it's a a two-lane road uh
and you have vehicles comeing the other
way the assumption would be that they're
going to slow down oncoming traffic and
move over um it's not always the
case thank you any other questions from
the committee representative St Clair
thank you Mr chair thank you Captain um
I just to follow up on representative
Hill
thing is there some way that uh the
state police or somehow to enhance the
the term if practical so that we don't
have people just say my God it's the law
in like that which can happen and does
happen quite frankly so do you see any
way that we maybe getting the
information out to people we can
practical certainly we can we can work
with with do high safety um AAA and work
on messaging that's the the biggest
thing I I want to say we we enforced
approximately three to 400 move over
laws last year which a state this size
is relatively small um again the
objective is to message it out and to
get the vast majority of of motorists to
see that vehicle that's on the side of
the road to slow down first and then if
safely they can move over um but a lot
of that does come down to messaging
thank you very much yes sir any other
gagy I realize I'm not thank you Mr
chairman I'm not a member of this
committee but now but I'm visiting
um Captain this is a possible scenario
and I've run into this situation before
when I could not move over safely I put
on I slow down and put on my four-way
flashes do we not have four away flashes
in all our vehicles today could we not
do that to warn people behind us that t
to slow
down you certainly can and if again if
you cannot move over um we're not
looking to to conduct a motor vehicle
stop on you and summon somebody that's
that's trying to be safe um this is to
avoid the distracted driver who isn't
paying attention for that that moment
drifts off the the side of the road and
and strikes a a person that's pulled
over um parked Stop Standing on the side
of the
road yes representative plemon thank you
Mr chair and thank you Captain um the
way this legislation reads to stop their
standing vehicle the way I read it is
even abandoned vehicles we would be
trying to you know move move out of the
way I have I've got a concern on that
does that is
that I don't have where this into
question do you feel that that also it
would apply with to the current wording
um there has been um work on that
verbage as far as having uh hazard
lights activated on the side of the road
it's not intended for the disabled
vehicle although we would strongly
encourage people again to slow down and
move over so that you don't strike that
that vehicle if it is close to the
shoulder of the road thank you followup
follow up to my initial question on uh
where it says warning lights uh I would
feel an amendment stating uh flashing
hazard lights Andor
flares that would then determine that
you need to move out of the way and it's
not an abandoned vehicle or something to
that effect uh I something identifying
this is an emergency situation and to
yield that would be my uh suggestion
thank you any further questions
representative sellers than thank you Mr
chair so on on um line seven of the bill
it says maintain a reduced speed so if
the speed limit is
70 if I reduce to 65 is that good I'm
trying to figure out what the reduced
be that won't be defined it's just going
to be to slow down
um as safely as you can we're not
looking for anybody
to reduce their speed so that they get
rear ended but again it's just to uh and
if you can put your hazard lights on if
that's appropriate in that moment then
then do so we're just looking for
operators to be to be
safe any further questions from the
committee
no chairman Walsh welcome back oh no
you're chairman thank you Mr chairman I
just just one question is there any
advantage to having uh laws like this in
the books even difficult to enforce uh
when it comes time for say convictions
in accidents the the because we I think
we can all see that this is not an easy
one to enforc is there a value to having
it in the
books there is Great Value to it uh as I
stated before the vast majority of
people are law-abiding citizens and if
they know that this is the law they're
going to abide by it not because they
are afraid of a consequence but because
it's the right thing to do so I think
having this on the books will greatly
enhance safety across the state thank
you any further questions from the
committee no one law one law
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair I'm sorry uh as representative
wbor so there is is there any penalty
that's what I'm getting it's is there
any penalty if there someone doesn't
slow
down yes it's a violation uh first
offense is
$75 uh second offense within 12 months
is
$150
any other questions not seeing any thank
you sir chair i' like to recognize Bill
Lambert from New Hampshire do
represented the
do asking for five
minutes uh who supports the bill welcome
sir good afternoon um thank you Mr
chairman and members of the committee uh
the dot does support this bill as we
testified in the Senate
Transportation um the sponsor reference
the the accident that happened just
before Christmas this year a young man
from Pittsfield uh I know people that
know the family uh and understand that
the um the deceased had called his F his
sister for assistance and she was the
first on the scene before the first
respond so I don't think you need any
more um evidence than that to show that
people that aren't moving over um if
you're not in the if you're not in the
the adjacent Lane to give more room for
error there's more of a margin for error
um so certainly any any more margin for
error from a highway safety perspective
is is a benefit and uh we would support
that we understand that it's tough to uh
to enforce um but if we can promote uh
that Move Over Law and to uh to respond
to representative Hills question
observation no data uh we have a similar
Bill moving over for bicyclists
graduated by speed and and I have seen a
fair trend of people and obviously
that's on two-way Road two directional
roads I have seen it trend of people
that are moving across the yellow line
to go around a bicyclist when there's
oncoming traffic I'm not sure what we do
to defeat that it seems illogical to me
that you would be willing to drive into
the opposing Lane when there's a car
coming to meet the Move Over Law uh I
don't know if that's so much the case on
on the divided highway when we get Lanes
in the same direction but I have seen
that on the bike law and I'd be happy to
answer any questions Sarah any questions
from the
committee representative put thank you
Mr chair
um will there be increased signage or
how how will this be promoted from the
do perspective the electronic signage or
it be um permanent signage put on the
sides of the road or what will that look
like thank you for the question um we
already work with safety on the on the
Move overr in general for uh right now
it says red red blue Amber lights or
blue red Amber whatever it is move over
um so we have to combine that kind of
simple concise message that we can put
on our changeable message signs with
something that's going to be um other
media so that people can correlate the
two um signing is difficult because it
the the language in the bill is
complicated it seems simple move over
when there's somebody on the side of the
road um but the nuances of the bill can
be complicated to put on a sign so um
the easiest thing that we can put on a
sign is the changeable message um signs
um those are changed once a month or
whatever to combine with a safety
program um so if we can use that uh
occasional signing to to support a
broader media campaign uh we'll work
with Department of Safety to do
that any further questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
sir chair i' like to recognize now Dan
Goodwin from Triple A who supports the
bill who does have some written
testimony and has asked for three
minutes thank you sir welcome to
transportation
right good afternoon thank you very much
for the record my name is Dan Goodman
I'm the public affairs manager for tripa
Northern England and as the chair said
uh I'm here in support of the bill um
these additions will provide drivers
with an additional layer protection when
they're on the side of the road sadly
has been mentioned there are examples of
motorists with disabled Vehicles being
struck on the side of the road as was
mentioned uh the young man in San Borton
um there's limited data but according to
a report from the Insurance Institute
for Highway Safety it is estimated that
over a three-year period 566 people were
killed and 14,000 were
injured um in crashes on all types of
Roads involving a disabled vehicle um
and then there was a classification
sadly about every year 23 roadside
workers lose their life at the roadside
um tending to disabled Vehicles every
year um we at the tri the AAA foundation
for Traffic Safety recently did a survey
where a quarter of the respondents are
unaware of the Move Over Law in their
state and there are F there is a law in
every
state um so the the intent of this law
has been talked about and what we really
want to get through is whether it's a
police officer whether it's a
firefighter whether it's tow truck dot
or a motorist with a flat TI Side Road
this is designed to create a behavior
change to improve roadside safety
regardless of the vehicle involved and
red redirect people a to think of the
person at the side of the road and so
with increasing speeds on our highways
it is difficult for motorists to
distinguish between the nuances of the
law this will simplify the law as uh Mr
Lambert from dot said in the variable
message boards which that the state does
a fantastic job if you travel around uh
New Hampshire I think stands above uh
with their the variable message uh signs
it's it's somewhat confusing you you're
driving down the road do I need to pull
over for this move slow down move over
for a red Amber so if we could have a
simplifi simplified message slow down
move over for all I mean that's not what
we're going to go with the state's going
to go with but something simple where
all motorists uh we can simplify that
for them I think it will create safer
roads for the state 20 states have this
law this expanded law where they're uh
for disabled vehicles or other motorists
so in conclusion New Hampshire's Move
Over Law could be enhanced by this by
passing this includes protections for
motorists that find themselves roadside
this would also help clarify confusion
and create a standard for slowing down
and passing stopped or standing Vehicles
as an advocate for the safety of all
those working or stranded at the
roadside tripa encourage you to support
this bill and to bring awareness to the
move over laws and help improve Highway
Safety in the state thank you and be
happy answer any questions thank you
Sarah any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much thank you that is our last person
for um this particular Bill I'm going to
close the hearing on SB
465 uh give us a few minutes and we will
thank
okay be at 28 I'd like to start the
hearing on
sb510 relative to a sale of a vehicle to
a Massachusetts resident and the chair
would like to recognize Senator Fenton
again welcome back sir been a
while thank you uh Mr chair and members
of the committee for the record again I
am Senator Donovan Fenton I represent
district 10 and I'm here to introduce
Senate Bill 510 this bill would repeal
the requirement for a retail Motor
Vehicle Dealer to submit a form
notifying the DMV of a car sale to a
Massachusetts resident this would allow
the dealer to issue a temporary plate to
a Massachusetts customer currently every
state in America including Hawaii and
Alaska recognize New Hampshire New
Hampshire's temporary plate there is
only one state that does not and that is
Massachusetts one of their main reasons
was that they do not issue their own
temporary plates that changed in 2022
when they did in fact start issuing
their own temporary plates PL which New
Hampshire recognizes so we recognize
their temporary plate but according to
this they don't recognize ours
Massachusetts customer cannot leave New
Hampshire with a car they bought until
the dealer fills out a form for the
Massachusetts registry in the New
Hampshire DMV by issuing a temporary
plate that gives the seller time to get
proper insurance and documentation to
the Massachusetts DMV or RMV and the
customer does not have to wait the
selling dealer still has to register the
car for them in Massachusetts so the
paperwork is still being done but this
gives the customer the ability to have a
temporary plate just like every other
customer in America gets uh this is a
Commerce fairness issue and for the
record I'm a car dealer and I do issue
temporary plates and I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you sir any questions
committee not seeing any thank you sir
that must have hit cross every te and
every eye you
know it's easy thank
you chair now like to recognize Dan
Bennett from the New Hampshire Auto
Dealers
Association uh who's asking for two
minutes uh in support of the bill
welcome
sir uh thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I will be brief I know
it's getting towards the end of your
work session I'm probably the last
lobbyist between you and break so um
this will be real quick Senator Fenton
did a fantastic job um introducing the
bill and summarizing the issue as you
know nhada represents 500 businesses in
New Hampshire um today uh just on behalf
of our franchise and independent car
dealers we're here U to support s sp510
it really is a fairness issue uh the
30,000 foot view pretty simple summary
is if Mass dealers can sell to New
Hampshire customers why can't New
Hampshire dealers sell to mass customers
um pretty basic um it's uh correct as
you heard for years um New Hampshire or
excuse me Massachusetts did not have a
template program so they did not honor
them they now do um but as a result of a
few years back they put RSA uh 26156 a
into statute that said a New Hampshire
dealer will not issue a template and
what you will instead do is a little 3x5
form that you report to the New
Hampshire DMV to report the sale so that
the DMV could be able to track how many
vehicles were sold in the state of New
Hampshire um they used traditionally
they could just do it by counting
templates right then you know but if
you're not issuing templates they never
know so what this bill actually does is
repeal that 56a um provision um the
current process is is timec consuming
and costly um to the dealer and the
consumer uh under the current system you
either have to sell the car in two
visits buy it go down go to the R&V get
the information prove Insurance plates
come back and then do a second trip or
some dealers actually employ um and pay
for a runner to go to the Mass RMV do
all the paperwork wait in line um and
then come back while the customer is
actually stuck waiting at the dealership
to buy the vehicle of their choice so um
this would remove that um and really um
level the playing field um to benefit
both dealers and and consumers so with
that being said we hope you support uh
sp510 um and if I can take any questions
and looks like there are thank you Sirah
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm not the brightest bulb in
the world so are you saying that a New
Hampshire dealer
um would be issuing or can issue with
this if this were to pass a
Massachusetts um temporary plate uh
thank you for the question represent
Hill um no sir they will actually a New
Hampshire dealer will issue a New
Hampshire template to the Massachusetts
customer the same exact way they're
doing right now to someone from Maine
Vermont Conneticut New York it's a New
Hampshire template is issued to the to
the
purchaser follow up um okay so does that
uh what what changes with Massachusetts
not recognizing the New Hampshire
temporary plate by us passing along so
what Massachusetts used to say and what
we were told um as dealers and I believe
also as the DMV but but um I don't want
to respond for them is that
Massachusetts does what we've been told
we're told Massachusetts does not honor
New Hampshire templates because
Massachusetts does not have it template
program M so since Massachusetts now has
a template program we would infer that
they will in fact honor the New
Hampshire template because now they do
program additional followup thank you
but they don't have to right I mean
isn't Massachusetts making their own
rules and so we are passing a law saying
Massachusetts shall recognize our
temporary plates now that you have one
is that am I missing something what
we're actually doing this bill is not
dictating to to Massachusetts what they
have to do is we're dictating to New
Hampshire dealers that they're allowed
to issue templates to a customer really
no matter what state they live in now if
what Massachusetts State Police chooses
to do is line up a bunch of blue
explorers at the line between Salem and
and what ha whatever the town may be you
know I can't I can't speak for what
Massachusetts and and state police will
do in in terms of their policy but what
this bill does is because it allows New
Hampshire dealers to issue templates to
Massachusetts customers okay thank you
representative
clemon thank you Mr chair thank you and
Mr Hill I representative Hill to ask
most of my questions my last my final
question is just do you foresee an
increase in Revenue uh Auto Revenue
sales uh should this pass on buying
vehicles in the taxfree state of New
Hampshire
uh my crystal ball is broken but I would
hope so um make the what it would do is
it would make the the sales process for
a Massachusetts customer who wants to
come to a New Hampshire dealer a little
bit
easier thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you sir thank you members of the
committee chair like now recognize uh
director morasco again welcome sir uh
from the New Hampshire DMV uh he says
information testimony for two minutes
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee John morasco director of the
DMV uh I'll be very brief everything has
been covered thus far in the testimony
um I would say from a DMV standpoint um
the gains that we see in this bill are
the forms so it's a three-part form that
has to be completed at the time of
purchase uh I'm told that we have tens
of thousands of these in boxes at the
DMV that are stacked up in the
registration Bureau um and that takes
time to process those when they come in
so there's a cost savings on not
producing the forms any longer and um
there's a savings on time with not
taking those forms in and handling them
at the DMV I'm happy to take any
questions thank you sir any questions
from the committee representative
sellers thank you Mr chair so I'm just
trying to understand if we're going to
allow this now right into those people
that live in Massachusetts as soon as
they drive back to Massachusetts with a
New Hampshire temporary plate are they
going to get fined on their end and
maybe blame us for something is that
possible so that's a very good question
um you know I leave that to the sponsor
um and others that would want to testify
to that those are conversations that
have been had I've heard conversations
about and I don't know if it's in motion
as far as a a disclaimer to be given out
um at the time of purchase um so that
the uh the individual knows that the
temporary plate um is not recognized by
Massachusetts at this time
but that's
uh from a DMV standpoint I'll just speak
to the financial aspect of it and the
processing part I that's a little larger
than what I would get into here
representative Fenton you have a answer
to that yeah I can I can answer that we
SP we spoke about this in Senate it's
always good sitting next to you you
know we spoke about that in Senate
transportation and you know it is kind
of at your will to do that and you know
there would be disclaimers written like
hey you're purchasing car you have the
option if you want that temporary plate
or not you don't have to accept it we
can go through the RMV which is the the
Massachusetts DMV or you can take the
temporary plate um you know we don't
make laws based on other states you know
this is New Hampshire every state and
Hawaii recognizes the temporary plate
except Massachusetts but now they have
their own temporary plate
system did that answer your
question may follow up yeah um the
question really was I don't want to see
any blowback on new campire because they
crossed the state line with our plate
you know saying it was all right to have
yeah absolutely representative I
appreciate the question and I don't
think the dealers want to feel that
blowback either or the Independent Car
Store that's selling that car or you
know the body shop that's selling that
car it really comes down to you know the
awareness aspect that like hey you can
now issue a temporary plate FYI you know
Massachusetts has their own temporary
plate system but also Mr customer you
know why don't you acknowledge that this
the disclaimer that you know New
Hampshire you know and Massachusetts
aren't the best of
friends representative Fox thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Senator um so C if
I understand correctly currently
Vermont uh Maine Connecticut issues
temporary plates to Residents that live
in Massachusetts is that correct so
every every thank you for the question
representative so every state around us
every Hawaii everyone recognized New
Hampshire's temporary plates and now
Massachusetts is issuing their own
temporary plates which we all recognize
except that you know we have this repeal
that we're doing that would now allow us
to issue that Massachusetts customer at
Crawford thank you Senator it's nice to
see you it's good to see you so would it
not be easy if you're talking about a
disclaimer to when when you sell the
vehicle
um I read all the things that they you
know I buy a new vehicle you're the only
one that does that well I do because I I
buy a car every three years but um if I
was asked to sign a disclaimer you have
a signature there you're you're sending
them off uh with them signing a
disclaimer that they know if they take
that plate and they drive in
Massachusetts they could be stopped I
mean isn't that
enough representative thank you for the
question um you know I would never
assume enough for you know a buyer or
anything like that but um you know it
comes down to they don't have to take
the temporary plate if they don't feel
comfortable you can you know dealers
still have to register their car and
alert the DMV that we are selling this
car to Massachusetts the only difference
now is that we can issue them a
temporary
plate representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman if I had known this many
questions I would have sat back you know
shouldn't yeah right so the question for
me is do we know if any of those other
suring states that sell to Massachusetts
customers have they adopted this same
approach of of Simply passing a lar in
their state and and are they having
problems when when those people from
Connecticut and the other states drive
back to Massachusetts are they rep are
they recognizing those temporary ples
representative thank you for the
question I'm not sure what other states
do in terms of how you know their
vehicle is licensed and their temporary
plate and how you know you know
insurance if they can have that
temporary plate so you know it's a
really good question um I haven't heard
any issues of you know uh these plates
being issued to
Massachusetts um you know right now
customers who buy a new car with a
temporary plate New Hampshire are
driving through Massachusetts so they
are passing through um I don't know if I
can I apologize if I don't have the
answer for you thank you representative
clemon
represent okay representative
gagy thank you for your your Indulgence
Mr chairman this one is for director
morasco couldn't the governmental
entities in this state get together with
the governmental entities in
Massachusetts and come to some
reciprocity agreement that says well we
honor yours honor
ours excellent question representative
gagy um we we have spoken about that uh
the senator I have spoken about that I
have spoken with the RMV director in
Massachusetts Colleen ogelby uh
wonderful leader there um we have talked
about just that getting together and
maybe speaking with some elected
officials in mass and trying to rectify
the uh the problem um in the initial
stages of conversations though it was
explained to me that it's um be quite an
uphill battle because it's a fiscal
issue there and um that doesn't mean it
can't be done and I'm not saying that we
shouldn't be investigating that and
doing that um but BAS B on the first
phone call or two that I had didn't look
like that was going to be something that
was going to be quick um to be able to
pull off but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't continue to try for that
representative representative Jack uh
thank you uh if I'm if I'm a Vermont
resident and I buy a car in New
Hampshire not only do I walk out with
the temporary plate I walk out with a
registration certificate uh and that has
a Vermont so I've Got a New Hampshire
temporary registration uh with a Vermont
residence address is that how that's
going to work and it would be the same
if it was a Massachusetts
address yes believe
yeah
yeah any other questions from the
committee representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair and thank you
both for being here
um the world has changed as far as the
way the car dealerships work uh many
people now are buying online and taking
they're not going into the showrooms
anymore they're buying online taking
delivery
and there's a lot of Interstate buys now
because people are just finding the car
they want
online but doesn't this ease the way to
sell to Massachusetts residents if if we
pass this bill who are you asking
representative I I guess it would be you
Senator um I'll hand yes
sir I I would agree yes I mean there's a
lot going on still with an online sale
you have Banks involved things like that
you still have to be present for
paperwork but you know we're trying to
make everyone's lives easier and you
know it's a reciprocity and a and
frankly a Commerce issue you know there
are there are neighbors we recognize
their temporary plate and they get sign
plate representative sers thank you last
question for me this uh to the director
he did say this is going to save you a
lot of money is that correct
I don't want to say a lot of money I I
haven't done the calculation
on well I I think it's going to be more
than that certainly with the uh with the
three-part form and the fact that we
have tens of thousands of those coming
in um so those are costly in this day
and age to produce um but an exact
dollar figure I I don't have for you but
I could probably get it I actually have
a text in to to see in the last year how
many of those forms we took in on those
Mass Massachusetts resident sales so I
once I have that number then I can
calculate it for you I can get you
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you both thank you
very much Ron f r CER
run at this point that was the last uh
speaker we have so I'm going to close
the hearing on SP
510 um let's take a few minutes um
representative sellers do you have the
amendment that you can pass around for
our exec session while we take a few
minutes uh pass those around and we'll
start the exact session shortly it's
right
there
e
all
right okay thanks everybody uh I'm going
to reopen the executive session on House
Bill
1637 uh I we've all had an opportunity
to read the
amendment okay why don't we start with a
motion uh to get to get started is there
a motion about the
pass representative sers since I caused
all this work thank you Mr chair I'll
make a motion that the amendment the
bill let's just start at the beginning
just not to pass it this moment we'll go
through the whole process yeah so I'll
make a motion on the bill of
37 as ought to pass okay motions ought
to pass is there a second repres
seconded by representative Hill uh the
bill is open for further Amendment uh
chair recognizes representative sellers
thank you Mr chair I'd like to offer
Amendment uh 2024 D1
1222 as an amendment thank you sir do I
have a second to the amendment second
second representative Gorski and once
again I thank you personally um would
amendment uh yes I can speak to it
unless the chair has other information
that I'm not aware of okay so let me
just go through here then and and uh
hopefully highlight some of the things
that happened and uh since we've been
gone from earlier today first of all on
page one nothing actually changed there
so what we talked about this
morning um on page two online
three uh again we took out and we uh we
said no we put a law enforcement and
then it we put in shall not where it
just said shall okay so that was taken
care
of uh then the next big change is down
on lines
27 um again we had linear now has cracks
but it goes on there
uh it had uh in a seal beam in a seal
beam headlight all right shall cause
inspection failure right cracks in a
seal
beam headlamp shall cause inspection
failure all right so that's my
understanding is the if it's a plastic
lens type of uh is that how that works
no it isn't so I don't know what that
is if I can the seal beams like the old
fashioned ones glass and the reflector
it's all in one so when the glass is
broken it's broken yeah thank you okay
there you go so they we're trying to
differentiate there at this point okay
um and so it goes on in there you guys
had a chance to read it but we ALS I
also had when I was talking to OS they
they were showing us uh another R law or
that uh Pennsylvania had and they they
used the word on line 31 they clouded or
op oxidized you know so we added that
just for more a little more clarity and
not that but that whole line couple
lines there so you know there is no if
ends and butts this is really spelled
out at this point okay on on this again
we're looking at the front lights so um
going on from there on page
three
um and I'll go go back but in any case
here again we're talking about the uh
the directional in this case here but
big part here and also on page two was
put in here is that we we're able to use
a tape where it's called
on uh what line here uh 8 and n i looks
like cracks in a directional signal that
are covered by color matching Automotive
lens tape and that's what the that's
what they call it so uh shall not cause
okay and that's also on the on the uh
front light as well and the key there is
the um color matching
Automotive um lens tape all right so
that's the change and then um going here
on trying to see if there's any change
on lines 15 16 17 we added the reflected
tape
again all right and the last part uh we
we did take out um the windows going up
and down that has been removed all right
so that's no longer in here
and then also on the break uh The Brak
Parts here uh the biggest change here
was I think it's on the last
page uh where it's uh line two which it
shows evidence of delimination on the
friction surface we took out uh
extensive pity all right Al
together those were the changes uh from
this
morning thank you sir um let me just
clarify a couple of things um the only
one I'll mention at this point in terms
of the fogging that was added fogging
in clouding or oxidizing
um just about well usually it's on the
exterior because of sun damage uh but I
do not know of an inspection station
that does not have a rubbing compound
and that's usually the solution uh
within five minutes they can polish it
back to clear no failure but at least
it's back to bright light again so just
to explain what the solution is that's
why it's not going to
fail um I will say there was a
conversation about the
inspections versus a 20-day plate I
can't solidify any direct problem right
now I'm just letting you know some of
the things were brought up um when we
were speaking a minute ago uh in other
words a 30-day grace period for a 20-day
plate there may or may not be something
certainly nothing needs to stop us for
moving forward with this today obviously
there's be opportunities if we find it's
a
problem
and other than that I'll open it up to
anybody else any other
questions
really oh go ahead on that on that 20
20-day plate it there is it's there is a
little difference there so On's if a
20-day plate was issued versus if a
sticker was already on the vehicle you
know at that point so there is a slight
difference
so yeah it may be fine I'm just letting
you you know what was brought up as a
possible point to which we can handle
later if need be but I think we're going
to be okay the way it
committee representative Hill I Just
Want to Thank John it there a lot of
work here and you you uh hung in there
thanks a
lot yes I agree thank you very much
again I I hate to say
this page four line
two show evidence of the elimination on
the friction
surface I know we said to remove the
word ex extensive but we remove the word
pitting as well do we want to leave that
alone or do we want to read the word
pitting just throwing that out
there go ahead Mr chair when I was over
at OLS we came up with the trying to
figure out another word for extensive
another word for pitting and it just
seem to be you know there's no easy way
to describe the surface you know enough
to say well is it two or three pits or
is it 35 pits you know you know it's
it's you know so we we just figured
maybe leaving it out would probably be
best all
together I'm fine with that would you
SES I think relative this to this
question um I want to do a little bit
more research and maybe we can if it
does need to be changed back a little
bit uh we can cooperate on a floor
Amendment uh or I like to keep things
within our control if we can um and if
it doesn't so I I I I don't see that one
little thing as being sufficient enough
for us not to move forward um but we
will do a little bit of work about that
I'll do a little bit of work about that
and consult with everyone about uh
whether we need a floor Amendment for
Thursday
okay uh well it wouldn't be this coming
Thursday anyway which is good so it
anyway I believe you are right so that
could give us we have plenty of time and
and so you know there's going to be a
couple because this is fresh and I do
agree with ranking member that we
usually do keep things here um we do
have options if we did over look
anything but I agree it's nothing worth
holding back on moving
forward yeah anybody else on the
amendment seeing none all those in favor
of adopting Amendment 2024
1222 raise your
hands I and opposed all right so the
okay so our motion on the floor is ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1637
any other comments from the
committee questions comments seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the RO when
she's ready again the motion is ought to
pass as
amended Vice chairman Gorski yes yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill yes
representative de yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
gagy yes representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Romo yes representative veu yes
representative Jones
yes representative mandon yes
representative Jack yes representative
um elberger yes okay and chairman Walsh
zero I did hear a motion for consent
without objection consent it'll be our
committee recommendation is adopted
question question about if we put it on
consent does that make it more difficult
okay and if it does for whatever reason
I can pull it myself so we we'll leave
it on consent um on that being said
again thank you representative sellers
for listening to all of us and doing all
the leg work but thank you everybody
else too because we've been spending a
good we spent a good portion of this day
and the last time we were here talking
about this bill so it's good to see
something moving in in in the right
direction um are we back here next week
here's where we're out hold on one
deadlines okay so crossover is on April
11th so far I've gotten eight bills from
the Senate we heard four today and I did
that just to basically fill the day uh
my plan was to not meet again in the
committee until after crossover I I
would not like to schedule my last five
or four I should say and then find out
we get one on crossover and have to come
back for one bill so why don't we wait
for crossovers to like then I'll
reschedule or schedule the rest of our
Senate bills um hopefully we don't get
anymore so let's cross our fingers uh so
that's my plan so I'm thinking we're
looking
middle of April before we come back
sometime uh so you know we have
until May
23rd so we've got plenty of time we got
plenty go
Ahad if that school vacation week is the
last week of April April 22nd so that
week if there's possibility of not being
committee that week that would be
helpful to some that's fine too we can
stretch it even longer again we've got
till May May 23rd report I don't want to
wait that long but it's not like we're
under the gun by any stretch we got
plenty of time so anything else for the
good of the cause any other questions
nice visiting it's been great to have
our great to have our Our Guest today
and and and representative gagy it's
great to have you back home we we still
miss
[Laughter]
you yeah all right thanks everybody
right